we have a clip here speaking of AI uh
from Brian Cranston who I loved as Tim
Whatley on Seinfeld he's great as the
father on Malcolm in the Middle oh he's
breaking so great in it yeah a fantastic
actor he also uh played LBJ in a play uh
Zach you want to cue this up where he's
he's he's got a message to the head of
the Disney Studio and all the other
suits
uh we've got a message for Mr Iger
[Applause]
I know sir that you look through things
through a different lens
we don't expect you to understand who we
are
but we ask you to hear us and beyond
that to listen to us when we tell you we
will not be having our jobs taken away
and giving to robots
we will not have you take away our right
to work and earn a decent living
and lastly and most importantly we will
not allow you to take away our dignity
[Applause]
Robert how do you how do you respond to
that well first of all I love Brian
Cranston so much uh
and I I mean I'm a writer so I'm like
yeah I'm making jokes in my head like
really take away your dignity your your
you you play Make Believe for a living
let's let's but but I I think as an
actor
it is much more worrisome and I don't
think it's a good replaced by a robot
it's just that you're not gonna have to
pay Brian Cranston because you got Brian
Cranston already in on your servers and
you can kind of make Brian Cranston do
and say whatever you want to make Brian
Cranston do and say and it is true that
the the Studios have been planning that
because the one thing they wouldn't back
down on the reason sag went out I think
one of the reasons went out
um is because they said all right well
for you know big name actors would be
one thing but if you're just a
background artist meaning an extra what
we call atmosphere
once we get you
on you know whatever we've modeled you
digitally we can use you in anything
forever for free now do we know that
that is the the contract or the rules
that are being discussed because I've
read that that's a misrepresentation
yeah we're talking about this particular
shoot but yes that is the yes they they
have clarified that but if you're a if
you're a writer
you kind of feel like uh you know what
you're you're you're you're you're
you're gonna need a writer to fix the AI
it may be a first draft but you're gonna
have to pay a writer and we'll just just
change the minimum so you have to pay me
more and even though it's a second draft
based on an AI draft which is never
going to be right just that Executives
don't want to they don't want to read a
script let alone type in
how to write it I don't know most
Executives don't read right so they
don't even you know so but an actor is
different an actor is fundamentally
different and they I understand why
they're afraid there's you know there's
a in the new season of black mirror
there's an episode uh that is built
around this concept that uh you know
Salma Hayek is her her likeness has been
captured and she's being used in a in a
in a show kind of not quite against or
well because somewhere deep in the terms
of service she had agreed to all of this
There Are Rules already in laws against
using the likeness of people
um you know so it seems and again it may
be maybe not for uh an extra background
artist but for somebody like Brian
cramps and that seems unlikely
um is it I mean like when I hear
Cranston you know who delivers all of
those lines fantastically but yeah I'm
listening to like hey let's go break
those looms you know he was on 44th
Street let's just go over to the Garment
District and you know there's a bunch of
selling machines that are really you
know screwing up how you know how much
more money we could make per race or
something like that I don't know you
know it just seems so far-fetched
um as to be kind of risible as a main
focus of of anxiety I mean of anxiety I
think there's a lot of anxiety because
your industry is going through a massive
restructuring and as you were saying rob
nobody knows how this is going to play
out in any meaningful way but like that
particular concern
strikes me as odd you know theater you
know actors have been around since you
know before Christ
yeah and they're probably gonna be
around after he comes and uh you know
and wasn't an actor who killed Lincoln
let's let's let's yeah right yeah um uh
I I hear you I I understand I think I
understand what you're saying I would
say there are probably two
um
they're sort of two levels here and the
top level anxiety is something you also
see in the writers which may not be
connected to the immediate threat but is
sort of is indicative of the general
anxiety which is that these all of this
these Technologies are designed to
remove what I do which has always been
subjective and was already incredibly
risky
um and to take me entirely out of this
out of the out of the the business right
um and then on a for the actors on a
fundamental or a closer level
um part of especially I mean any actor
but I mean a big actor like Brian
Cranston but anybody else is that when a
project goes over
or when a project needs reshoots which
they all do they got to pay you
by the day
and for some people if you're at Brian
Cranston level that's a whole lot of
money that's actually that's a big part
of it could can be a big part of your
annual income and if you're a mid-range
actor they need you back to reshoot this
or reshoot that or whatever they need
you back for
and if they don't have to bring you back
if they can kind of within the context
even the context is one title the same
title you know whatever that movie was
or project was you're still there they
don't have to pay you
for additional work that they've created
in the box that isn't effect work but is
in fact just error correction or
whatever
um
that's a bad road for the actor that's a
bad road to go down if you're an actor
and that's something you probably want
to protect so it isn't quite something
so much that you're breaking again it's
it's completely understandable that
actors and writers uh you know want to
get as much money as they can for the
work that they do I you know that but
then when you pull back a little bit it
just seems like other industries that
have automated other industries that
have you know used technology they
figure out a way
um I mean and it seems like Hollywood
you know for lack of a better term is
the last industry that is going to be
like you know what you've seen Bryan
Cranston already we're going to give you
uh uh uh you know a fake Brian Cranston
and you're gonna love it
um you know because and if you can if
you can replace Brian Cranston and
Breaking Bad with Brian Cranston from a
Mac Book
then maybe you know maybe there's not as
much uh Magic going on or I I just
strikes me as it's a it's a heavy ask to
you know regular people who just are
watching TV or going to movies who are
paying more every year
Etc you know right like you know but the
important thing is that Brian Cranston
get that extra check
um but that's what's fair in the world
well what's fair is if you I mean the
difference is that if you were making
you know if you're a famous sweater
Knitter you know
then you may not like the loom because
it makes sweaters right a lot cheaper
and faster than you can knit them but
you and you really can't say much about
it but you can say if someone sell if I
make a sweater and a loom and I say this
is a nicolespie
yeah you have every right to say no way
no way that's not Nicholas I mean
Gillespie's the guy who knit the sweater
and I didn't hit that sweater right and
so this isn't really anti-technology
it's more like okay you can make you can
you can make a movie now and ai's a fake
person and it'll probably look pretty
good what you could make your own movie
star if you want you just can't call
that movie star Brian Cranston yeah well
I think I mean certainly from a
Libertarian point of view that makes
subtle sense because then we're talking
about fraud or misrepresentation and
there's no moral issue there but I also
I I suspect that there'll be an
aesthetic issue where it's like people
you know people will want the real Brian
Cranston they'll want the authorized
edition of then they'll have to they
should pay and Brian Cranston should
make whatever the the absolutely can but
but I say also and even now it's the
studios and the streamers that have
brought us to this position right
because they're the ones that have
created so much content in this
ridiculous War they're having for
streaming services that makes no
Financial sense
Financial moves they have done and the
only way and I say it hurt it kills me
as a writer but the only way
um for them to distinguish a prod one
project from another is with a star like
a recognizable face that's how you get
people to watch so Brian Cranston stuck
and every other act good actor stock
went way up as it should have because
he's got something special you now you
can't say that you can't say to people
well we're going to take that special
thing away no you created the conditions
that have created this now you have to
live with your own bad uh your own Bad
Business modeling let's uh speaking of
business models can I just register
by one uh worry uh with it because I I
can totally understand where Brian
Cranston is coming from and especially
some of the people who aren't at Brian
cranston's level who might be afraid
that their image is going to get
exploited over and over again
but what what I worry about with um kind
of an overreach would be that Hollywood
I think sometimes has a tendency to draw
boundaries or or gatekeep a little bit
too tightly with whether it comes to the
use of new technology or intellectual
property
these are all tools for creating new
things and if you're going to gatekeep
access to those tools you're inevitably
going to make it harder for the upstarts
the people who don't have a lot of
institutional backing to
uh to to use them
um and you know there's been a lot of uh
fights over the years uh to expand fair
use protection of re repurposed material
that's a fight we've fought alive
because we're in documentaries and so we
will uh you know be commenting on other
material and then you'll get you know
take down notices and Hollywood's been a
major Force against that so that that is
what I worry about with kind of over
defining like what is AI like what is
generated by AI what is like you know my
image is if it's if it's sort of based
on an image of another person but it's
not really them is that going to be
covered by this prohibition those are
kind of like the the Margin Call type
cases that I guess I I worry about the
most I don't know how it's all you know
going to resolve
um and and there's certainly arguments
on both sides but but that that's kind
of what looms large when I think about
it yeah
I have a solution okay
because
um
if you go back to the glory years right
when there was more independent film
those true independent film when when is
this well you know pick it you know
sometime in the late 80s we'll say 80s
right so okay
just by the tail end of the studio
system kind of fell apart
um I mean you know from the 1920s on a
block booking went and the FEDS got
involved and then TV and then the fed's
gotten re-involved where they had the
financial interests and syndication
rules and then that kind of like you
know they they sort of be deregulated
and sort of around the 80s people
started to like you could really make a
lot of money with an independent film
and you could really make a lot of money
as a small Studio
um an unaffiliated small Studio by the
way uh
that that is the solution
for innovation in almost every industry
but definitely innovation in show
business or at least to keep the doors
open or more open for change the what
what this the irony is that the the the
the very people who seem to understand
that sort of in their DNA which is the
Techno to technology people from Silicon
Valley the minute they got into the 310
212 213 area code they completely threw
it away and they decided oh I want to
have a vertically integrated studio with
both my exhibitors and my studio doing
the same thing I want to eat what I kill
and nobody in show business has ever
made any money eating what they kill you
eat what that guy kills a little bit and
you give him some of your stuff and
everybody kind of gets rich and they
didn't do that and if they did that
um we would not be here in this position
that was an excerpt of our reason live
stream with Rob long talking about the
writer's Guild strike and the sag-aftra
strikes if you want to watch another
excerpt go here and if you want to watch
the whole thing go here and make sure to
come back next Thursday at 1 pm eastern
time when reasons live stream we'll be
talking with somebody who's very
interesting saying stuff that you
definitely want to hear